everyone Steve Weintraub with Collider
I'm here with the people behind wounds
at Sundance before we get started I want
to give a huge thank you to Kia
Telluride for being a great sponsor
because they're the only reasons we get
to do stuff like this is having sponsor
Sundance as as expensive I was gonna
make a joke and say I'm wondering what
you have to do to get the free car but
I'll bet you there's probably a way of
doing it she's like I'm completely
teasing but so first of all congrats on
being part of Sundance everyone watching
this will not have seen the movie maybe
two people will have so I hate doing the
generic thing but talk a little bit
about what the film is about and for
each of you who you guys play sure the
film is about a bartender in New Orleans
called will play by a wonderful army
hammer here who is a very charming
affable guy a very cool guy but he's
also quite shallow doesn't take anything
in life seriously as a very easygoing
life and likes to keep it that way
but one night he finds a cell phone left
behind his bar picks it up and looks at
what's on it just to see whose it is
and and he sees some really disturbing
stuff that turns his easygoing life into
a living nightmare yeah and how do you
get involved I am Army's best friend
slash most loyal customer in his bar
slash we have attractions Winky Winky
one of the things is you guys actually
filmed in New Orleans and talk a little
about what that added to the film and
why did you want to be in New Orleans
I mean it's based on a novella called
the visible filled by nathan balan groot
and nathan was actually a barton in new
orleans so so the setting of the film is
pretty much very important for the story
it's almost a character in the story i
mean it's not one of those like post car
films about like you know like oh come
to the city of new orleans it's a lot of
fun
but it's just it wasn't a novella and
and we just thought you know New Orleans
is such a fascinating place he has a lot
of history but also I always say that
like it has a very strange vibe it
almost feels like it's sitting on a
portal to another dimension for some
reason so I so it's just it's just it's
just perfect for the film and you see
why there are loads of cockroaches there
as well which helps the story for both
of you talk a little bit about filming
in New Orleans and what that city what
the city added to the film as Babic sort
of just suggests that I I always feel
New Orleans as feels very haunted to me
and old with history and souls that are
still wandering about which the film
sort of talks about you know the the
hollowness of self and what you choose
to fill yourself with and it you know I
feel like there's so much there to
consume and to you know that I think
there's darkness there that you can
culturally that you can I feel like
inherit for yourself in a way I don't
know if you think about the sort of
Voodoo culture it's like old you know
what I mean they think there's there's a
lot of heaviness there along with kind
of the the drunken frivolity of it all
which is also something I think we sort
of is discussed in the film is kind of
like the gluttony and the privilege of
that and you know I just also just love
New Orleans as a city and it has such a
beautiful character and is so unique and
gives a beautiful backdrop to to this
film plus they have 24-hour bars so
after you've finished doing a night
shoot at 7:30 in the morning if you want
to go get a drink no one judges you at
all you're not saying you ever did that
no no this is what I was told by babaçu
was drunk the whole time I am curious
though
a great cast you also Dakota Johnson I'm
curious what is it like in that initial
meeting talk about that first time you
guys met and what is it like because
obviously you you are you nervous going
in that you like I hope they like me and
for you guys are you like thinking and I
really hope he likes me yes I mean I met
army first stuffing and literally like
after five minutes we're best buds and
and sandwich as we Skype first before
meeting in New York and yeah there was
no awkwardness um it depends on the
situation with these lovely people there
were no awkwardness we did have a great
cast and I think that we got such a
great cast cuz we had we had we had Bob
that kind of behind it and anybody
anybody who really met with him or
Skyped with him or talked to him was
like yeah dude I like you let's see
let's do this where's the Chunin in New
Orleans hell yeah let's go and it just
became like a really I mean the movie
itself is is eerie and intense and and
sort of a smooth and steady descent into
darkness and madness but the vibe on set
was always really fun like we had a
great time making this movie I'm always
curious about the editing process
because that's ultimately the final
rewrite what did you learn from any
screenings that impacted the finished
film and when did you guys actually see
it was it when it was done done or did
you see like an earlier cut I saw
yesterday I was like I was like well
I'll just wait and watch it at Sundance
like let's just do that they're like
well no you have to do a whole day of
press before you're gonna get to see it
I'll go yeah that's fine yeah I'll wing
it I'll make [ __ ] up like that's what I
always do and press anyway and they're
like no you need to see the movie and I
did and I'm really glad I did yeah yeah
I think I have an old link somebody told
me that it's sort of changed a little
bit but I also was like I'll just watch
it at Sundance and then somebody was
like but the press yeah and so I saw it
yesterday afternoon yes and I'm glad I
did and the editing process was great i
wonderful other to Chris Barlow who
caught my first film under the show
as you said it is the final rewrite and
that's how I see yet it but it went it
went quite smoothly and I I ended up
making a film I set out to make and and
I'm very proud of it yeah
I'm always curious about memorable
moments from filming for each of you
what's the one day that you when you
think back on the shoot that you'll
always remember I remember we kept
pranking the ad was it the ad it was
also Babak it was it was really kind of
no that was not yeah yeah I found a big
bowl of chalk Brandon like I don't know
if it was like weightlifting chalk or or
whatever was and it was just this
massive bowl of chalk and it became a
game to see how many handprints I could
get on babak's back before he noticed so
I would just dip my hand in the chalk
and I'd walk over and I'd be like a big
hit a quick question I do what was the
thing about the day and then I and then
by the end of it here like 15 handprints
on his back and I fill this hole back
and then I was like who else do I get
and then I just went around set chalking
everything's being so friendly
today constantly yeah yeah we also had I
mean all of the days where there were
cockroaches on set were memorable just
because it was terrifying
[ __ ] hate Cochran they smell they
smell by the way I deal with cockroaches
so little that I didn't realize they
reek well especially like the ones we
had like we'd have buckets of
cockroaches what we're what there's a
Wrangler there was this was in New
Orleans we and we also had a dedicated
cockroach Wrangler couldn't lose one
yeah
because shooting would stop yeah and
you'd have to find the roach also I
remember the Wrangler being like you
know it's great about all these
cockroaches is they each have different
personalities and I was like my man you
are spending way too much time with
cockroaches if you're analyzing their
personalities like this thing needs to
just be stepped on right that's crazy
yeah and yeah I'm not down with
cockroaches either I tried like after we
filmed for a bit we'd all been dealing
with cockroaches enough that I was like
I think I'm over my phobia of
cockroaches like I think
do this okay Wrangler man I want you to
come over here and put a cockroach in my
hand and that will be me proving to
myself that I have truly mastered my
fear of cockroaches and then everyone's
like are you sure and I'm like yeah yeah
yeah come on it's no problem there's no
problem and these things are relatively
docile they just kind of like chill and
then he puts it on my hand
and I'm and I'm like okay okay I'm doing
it I'm doing it this is okay okay and
all of a sudden this thing hadn't moved
while it was sitting in the bucket
hadn't moved in God knows how long he
puts it on my hand and it starts running
up my arm towards my face and I just was
like I freaked out and I think I
reinforced my phobia of cockroaches as
opposed to conquering it right uh that's
amazing yeah and thank you for sharing
that story
have you ever filmed in downtown LA yes
so I was told I've been on sets downtown
LA and they I'm always like this isn't
that bad and they've said Steve why
don't you just look down a little bit
and I'm like what are you talking about
you look down in the ground moves yeah
and it's because of cockroaches and
insects and other things so Indiana
Jones wasn't that dramatic but you know
what I mean yes he was saying that newer
making this was an interesting adventure
it was good fun I want to switch a
little bit to get to know your Sundance
attendee I promise these are harmless a
few quick ones what team for the two of
you what TV show would you love to guest
star on and what TV show would you love
to guest direct your on one of the shows
to be on when I do the question with
everyone I would swear to you 75% of the
answers are Atlanta yeah like for real
of course of course but my other one is
Patriot I've seen Patriot I have Amazon
I was gonna say it's an amazon show I've
seen it it's awesome it's so great and
so funny and darkened and delightful
Patriot I would say
I don't know I'm always bad at questions
like this yes well I'll go with one of
my favorite shows the last year's
succession sure what is your version of
succession which you do your own spin on
it
or would it be alternate dark
cockroaches everywhere what you want to
skip or you know what escape a denim or
is really good okay do you have a
favorite sci-fi or fantasy film mmm-hmm
you're talking on nerds so I have many
so I don't I need to think and I can go
first yeah closing counter sure oh yeah
yeah 2001 yeah that one's really good
one popping into my head is ex machina
but I would say 2001 all phenomenal
films do you remember what film scared
you as a kid cuz they look great I know
exactly wasn't necessarily a film it was
a long music video that was Michael
Jackson Thriller directed by John Landis
yeah nightmares for a long long time guy
who makes really scary movies that's a
very delicate thing to scare you I was
really young I was like four or five and
my older brother was kind of mean showed
it to me and yeah couldn't shake it off
and I'm a massive win yeah I saw The
Grudge when I was 12 which was the first
horror movie I saw him for weeks I
couldn't finish my showers I I foolishly
was in the basement and like The
Exorcist came on on television and it
petrified me so badly that I couldn't
even move to get the remote so I sat
there in like a catatonic state and
Scarb I mean I still if I go into a
basement now
I will just start thinking about the
Exorcist do you remember what your first
movie or TV show crush was tiffani-amber
thiessen on Saved by the Bell
I understand that was quick I liked I
don't know III never have a quick quick
quick ones too this is this kind of
stuff it's cool
Michelle Pfeiffer and Batman Returns
do you own any movie or TV show props
other than like our own just could be
your own stuff but do you own any movie
or TV show props oh yeah I steal
everything off every movie I do like I
mean how much did I steal off our set
probably notes yeah if it's not nailed
down and it's the last day of shooting I
will sneak off with it yeah I take a lot
of the clothes so a lot of times depends
on them if it's like a big studio thing
and everything's a lock and inventory
but on smaller things I like the clothes
I'd take them did you take anything yeah
like some props from yeah I I took a
prop from this one and one from under
the shadow so yeah good he's just a few
last few that are really fast are there
have you watched a TV if you watch any
TV show all the way through more than
once yeah maybe yeah I mean I've
definitely seen all of Parks and Rec and
then I will occasionally go back and
watch other episodes again but I don't
think I've watched the entirety more
than once one of the all-time best
characters in TV history is what Ron
Swanson Swanson okay it's so good I
don't think I've ever rewashed an entire
series
this is guy I've watched Atlanta twice
both season and first season true
detective oh yeah I've seen procedure
this is this or that Star Wars or Star
Trek Star Wars Star Trek Star Wars game
of Thrones or breaking bed I've never
seen Game of Thrones so breaking bed
breaking that Han Solo or Indiana Jones
Indiana Jones my Han Solo is Indiana
Jones
Indiana Jones Han Solo my last question
for you guys for each of all three of
you do you remember what it was growing
up that said I want this is what I want
to do I want to make movies I want to be
in the entertainment industry
was there a performance or a movie and
you said oh my god I want to do that
Macaulay Culkin in home alone first
[Music]
sound of music I've heard that from a
number of people yeah it's not a music
and singing in the rain
Stephen stood over Tim Burton when I was
10 11 all of their films on that note
I'm just gonna say thank you sincerely
so much for coming in the studio
I hope these questions were not too
painful see what else you got
oh there's there's like others like
what's your background photo on your
phone which I'm happy to family right
you know stuff like that fly through
these bro see God uh what do you collect
did I ask you that nothing wait one
favorite superhero movie quickly yeah
one was Deadpool - I was gonna say
Deadpool - because honestly it's great
but I didn't want to feel like I was
playing up to the crowd and I had worst
job you've had being a runner
oh yeah yeah handing out flyers yeah I
very briefly sold concessions at a
concert and it was terrible
again sincerely I could ask you guys a
million other questions for example
x-force Deadpool three Atlanta season
three I believe you have something
coming up called Rebecca mmm-hmm when do
you start filming that this year no I
know I meant when you know we will start
shooting
probably end of May yeah you have a
director that I also like with that dude
I love them with me yeah
just throwing that out there but listen
I you guys gotta go thank you thank you
sincerely so much I really appreciate it
good to see you Steve
you